Sensor sizes play a role in all of this too.
Here I'm basically showing you the aspect ratio and
sensor size of a 35 millimeter standard, full frame camera.
So basically this is a 1 to 1 full frame, 35 millimeter, 24 millimeter.
Sensor of course that impacts the field of view of a camera that you use to
capture images.
Slightly smaller.
This is another sensor size that's widely used 28.7 to 19.1.
And the aspect ratio is no longer full frame, but 1 to 1.26.
This is yet another well known and widely used.
The aspect ratio in this one is 1 to 1.5.
These days micro four-third cameras are getting more common and
this is the sensor size for that.
Of course a micro two-third camera sensor size is this.
Other sensor sizes exist, 7.25 millimeter to 5.33.
And again, now you notice that we're moving from a much more
professional digital SLR all the way to handheld cameras or
pocket cameras or more instant you know, cell phone cameras.
This, for example, is a sensor for iPhone 5, 4.54 times 3.52 millimeters.
And of course we can keep on getting other type of sensor sizes.
But you noticed this is a sensor for
a professional camera all the way to kind of what's in mobile phones like this.